[Musique]
dans les années 60 la cia à financer des
expériences sur des patients en
psychiatrie ici à montréal
plusieurs victimes ont été indemnisées
on croyait cette histoire terminée mais
en voici un nouveau chapitre nous sommes
en 1964 viennent mais comme tâche à 5
ans elle a très hâte d'arriver à
destination
car aujourd'hui son père l'emmène voir
sa mère à l'hôpital
mon père m'a payé sur ses genoux et je
pouvais prendre le volant
c'était comme un jeu la voiture emprunte
la longue allée traversant le terrain de
l'hôpital jusqu'à l'institut alone
memorial de montréal un établissement
psychiatrique parmi les plus réputés au
pays après plus d'un demi siècle
diane se souvient de cette première
visite comme si c'était hier
son enthousiasme disparaît en entrant à
l'hôpital de creil oise
c'était comme une scène de vol au-dessus
d'un nid de coucou je voyais des gens
grenier en frappant leur tête contre les
murs un mérité la a6 est complètement
drogué j'avais beau n'être qu'une enfant
je voyais bien que quelque chose
clochait
mais ce qu'ils ignorent à l'époque c'est
que sa mère hélène macintosh tout comme
des centaines d'autres patients sert de
cobaye contre son gré pour les
expériences psychiatrique brutale menée
par le docteur you win cameroun
administration massive de médicaments
longue période de sommeil forcé électro
chocs à répétition
le tout en partie subventionné par le
gouvernement canadien et par la cia
[Musique]
charles thani est admis à l'institut
alone memorial en janvier 1957 il
souffre de violentes douleurs au visage
le docteur cameron y voit la
manifestation d'un trouble anxieux qu'il
va traiter à l'aide d'électrochocs et de
sommeil provoqué jusqu'à 50 jours l'avis
de monsieur dany va basculer se diviser
en deux avant son traitement à l'hôpital
puis après pour ce qui n'était pas le
même personne de tous
au lieu d'un traitement monsieur tanner
a été malgré lui soumis à une série
d'expériences visant à effacer sa
mémoire pour mieux la reconstruire
mk ultra est un projet sur le lavage de
cerveau mis sur pied par la cia ou tout
début de la guerre froide durant la
guerre de corée
des soldats canadiens et américains a
pas trier se met à prendre parti pour
l'ennemi communiste
les américains croient que les
soviétiques et les chinois ont inventé
une façon efficace de laver les cerveaux
la cia veut découvrir leurs procédés
l'ex agent de la cia john kringen le
confirmer au fil des states dès 1981 le
mandat était large on nous demandait de
développer tout genre de procédé qui
soit chimiques psychologique ou autres
pouvant permettre d'influencer le
comportement des êtres humains de la cia
sait qu'il ya un risque politique à
mener directement ce genre de recherche
elles financent donc une société écran
qu'elle nomme société efforts
d'investigation afi human ecology
société hébergée par une université
américaine la cia s'intéresse aux
travaux du docteur rioux en carbone co
fondateur de l'association mondiale de
psychiatrie
il est aussi directeur de l'institut et
alain de mémoriaux le docteur cameron ne
fait pas l'unanimité auprès de ses
collègues de travail
c'était un homme autoritaire
pitoyable assoiffé de pouvoir
stressé colérique de 1957 à 1962 de
docteur cameron obtient du financement
de la société écran soutenus par la cia
il reçoit aussi des subventions du
gouvernement canadien en 1962 hélène
macintosh
à 23 ans à la naissance de son deuxième
enfant elle fait une dépression son
médecin de famille je recommande le dr
cameron des preuves et ils m'ont promis
que j'allais pouvoir leur poser et qu'on
allait veiller sur moi durant mon séjour
à l'hôpital
elle ignore qu on va la soumettre à des
traitements expérimentaux extrême
électrochoc et vsd messages sonores
diffusés jour et nuit pendant des mois
de sommeil artificiel
ce traitement la ramener à une étape
quasi infantile à hausse
c'était infernal vraiment infernal
c'est un état impossible à décrire dès
que je commence à en parler je met à
trembler de tout mon corps on dirait que
mon corps ne veut pas jean tard
[Musique]
hélène n'a que quelques souvenirs épars
des années passées à l'institut a nommé
mario les électrochocs
une photo du docteur cameron mais je me
rappelle de lui
j'ai un souvenir très claire de sa voix
il m'avait acier ce devant un groupe
d'étudiants en médecine ou de médecins
résidents et leur a dit cette femme est
totalement incurable tout simplement
sans la moindre émotion
je me souviens des moments où il a
laissé sortir quand elle venait chez ma
grand-mère lesquelles mon thème bordés
dans ma chambre
une fois qu'elle était partie grand
maman venait me souhaiter bonne nuit et
je lui disais ne bouge pas les
couvertures n'y touche pas maman les
allées c'est comme ça et toute la nuit
j'essayais de dormir sans déplacer ni
couvertures hélène macintosh a passé
deux ans à l'institut allen mémoriaux
ses souvenirs lui ont été volés comme
des données effacées d'un ordinateur
[Musique]
aujourd'hui hélène vit en colombie
britannique
l'album de photos de famille est très
souvent une énigme pour elle mère et
fille ont toutes les deux souffert de
ces expériences sur le lavage de cerveau
et elles sont loin d'être les seuls
des victimes ont franchi ses portes par
centaines durant les années 50 et 60
chacune traîne une histoire d'horreur
comme celle karl kani et sa famille
découvre des années plus tard dans le
dossier médical de leur père dr khan
était très nerveux parce qu'après
peut-être trois ou quatre semaines
il a trouvé que mon père ait demandé de
te voir ma mère puis première chose dans
les sports
deuxième chose qu'est ce qu'il a fait il
a augmenté
l'électrochoc la méthode du docteur
cameron a plaidé structuration vise à
effacer la mémoire du patient pour mieux
la reconstruire dans les notes de
doctorat moins
il a donné 150e joueur il y avait eu 29
stations de recrues choc 21 et tapez de
joie sont la thérapie paige rosso du nom
de ses inventeurs consiste en une si
l'électrochoc de 20 à 40 fois plus
puissants que ceux utilisés dans les
traitements à l'époque
après quelques semaines le père d'alain
thani est réduit à un état infantile
jusqu'à devenir un continent
monsieur tanner sait pas où il est
souvent il est heureux et comme un
enfant ça se divisera en français ce
week end tech dont le talent est avec
cette patiente ne plus qu'on peut
c'était une chose qui la fait plus s'il
y en a un programme de traitement de
douleurs dans la phase retour
le gouvernement canadien se faire
rattraper par cette histoire
[Musique]
cet institut connu sous le nom de à la
mémoire de cette étude s'est mérité une
réputation enviable sur le plan
international pour les travaux qu'on n'y
a fait dans le domaine psychiatrique
jusqu'en 1977 l'institut ellen memorial
fait figure d'avant garde en psychiatrie
jusqu'à ce qu'un article du new york
times révèle l'existence du programme
secret de la cia le mk ultra on y
apprend qu'à la fin des années 50 la cia
à financer des expériences de lavage de
cerveau dans de nombreux établissements
américains mais aussi à l'institut ellen
memorial l'ailé psychiatrique de
l'hôpital royal victoria
[Musique]
mais ce qui s'était passé derrière ces
murs restera secret jusqu'à ce que
l'émission fifth estate de la sib ici et
d'autres médias révèlent la sphère en
1989 the state capitol
ils m'ont gardé endormi pendant 23 jours
je dormais il me bombardaient
l'électrochoc le public découvre avec
stupeur des expériences subies par les
patients on m'a fait toutes sortes de
tests on madone certains médicaments
jusqu'à 40 pilules par jour
ensuite on m'a donné des électrochocs
pourquoi donc j'allais pas peur pointage
et puis c'est quoi vous acceptiez quand
même de subir si j'étais réticent le dr
cameron était le meilleur en amérique du
nord
alors on avait une confiance et nous
le souvenir du docteur cameron n'est pas
le même pour tous gina blasberg a été
admise à l'institut et alone memorial à
l'âge de 15 ans mais n'a pas reçu des
électrochocs
ce qui explique peut-être qu'elle se
rappelle des réactions des patients à
l'endroit du dr cameron
certains étaient trop patins pour réagir
mais ce qu'il pouvait encore été
terrifiée on était tous terrifiés quand
il arrivait on ne voulait pas qu'il
s'approche de nous aucun patient ne
voulait se retrouver près du docteur
cameron
les révélations sur les expériences du
docteur cameron mène à une poursuite
intentée par neuf des victimes contre la
cia dont madame huard les patients
disent qu'on les a soumis à leur insu à
des recherches douteuses au plan médical
est même illégal mais les chances de
succès semblait improbable pour welmant
orly qu une des plaignantes avoir j'y
repensais en rentrant chez moi et je me
disais parfois tu penses vraiment gagner
contre la cia mais pour qui tu te prends
la cia est bien trop puissante
pourtant à la fin des années 80 la cia
conclu une entente avec les patients
canadiens qui reçoivent 90 mille dollars
chacun une victoire morale
puis le gouvernement canadien annonce un
programme de dédommagement en 1992
mais seuls les victimes qui ont été
ramenées à un état infantile par les
expériences seront indemnisés le
gouvernement précise n'avoir aucune
obligation légale ou morale de
dédommager ces personnes
le père d'alain thani est l'un de ceux
qui ont reçu un chèque de 100 mille
dollars
est-ce que c'était suffisant comme
compensation
si on ajoute toutes les thérapies que
les enfants à passer
c'est plus que ça des années en thérapie
mon père était beaucoup plus difficile
dans ses relations avec vous et avec
tout le monde
après son traitement c'était plus
difficile
finalement seuls 80 des anciens patients
du docteur cameron répondent aux
critères de l'aide fédérale
250 personnes voient leurs dossiers
rejetés sans compter ceux et celles qui
ignorent l'existence même du programme
et une fois la date limite passé c'est
impossible de réclamer une compensation
le programme exclut aussi les personnes
décédées mon père était dans ces
dernières minutes c'était new cross dans
thériault pierre qui a fait ça pour le
gouvernement
puis elle m'a dit prends l'avion vient
me voir pour demain matin 9 heures puis
je les ai faites
j'ai un jacques puis les jours après mon
père il est mort
23 ans après la fin du programme le
gouvernement croyait bien en avoir
terminé avec cette affaire mais il y a
quelques mois
elizabeth thompson journaliste à la bbc
examiné les comptes publics du
gouvernement fédéral
une donnée du rapport de 2017 mentionne
un mystérieux paiements liés aux
expérimentations de lavage de cerveau
d'une autre époque ça concernait le
dédommagement d'une personne ayant subi
la déstructuration war in memory of le
nom de la victime n'était pas divulguer
ni aucune autre information sur ce
paiement
la journaliste finit par découvrir que
la personne en question est en fait la
fille de jean style admis à l'institut
haleine les marioles en 1957 alors
qu'elle souffrait d'une grave dépression
post partum allison style n'a pas le
droit de dévoiler l'entente mais elle
peut nous parler de sa mère elle qui a
été privée de sa présence
après les traitements subis aux mains du
docteur cameron ils ont effacé tous ses
souvenirs
comment peut-on oser faire ça une êtres
humains selon allison à son retour de
l'hôpital sa mère était absente sur le
plan émotif autant qu'intellectuelle sa
relation avec son mari et ses enfants
n'a plus jamais été la même
en 1993 le gouvernement a rejeté la
demande du père d'aller seul il n'a pas
réussi à obtenir le dossier médical
prouvant que sa femme avait été victime
de traitements abusifs à l'hôpital
durant des décennies la famille dans
l'essonne a tenté sans succès d'obtenir
un dédommagement
je garde un gros dossier toute la
correspondance de mon père avec le
gouvernement il est décrit clairement
tous les traitements et toutes les
choses qu'on avait fait subir à ma mère
mais il nous manquait le dossier
principal
les années ont passé jean la merde
allison est décédé puis à 93 ans son
père meurt sans avoir réussi à
convaincre le gouvernement de donner
gain de cause aux victimes comme sa
femme jane mais en 2015 les choses
bougent en vertu de la loi d'accès à
l'information a laissé une demande le
dossier médical complet de sa mère
qu'elle reçoit par la poste
le wifi g reçu une grande enveloppe de
300 pages tiré du dossier médical des
informations caché durant des décennies
grâce auquel son père aurait réussi
depuis longtemps à prouver ce que sa
femme avait subi
parmi les notes découverte certaines
sont de la même même du docteur cameron
gymstill y est décrite comme hyper
active excessivement bavarde très peu
attentive très méfiante ayant un
comportement déplacé et pleurant sans
raison valable
la description d'une femme qui ne peut
plus jouer son rôle de mère à cause de
traitement du docteur cameron
jean style a reçu au moins 24 sessions
intensives d'électrochoc
ces informations ne sont jamais parvenus
à votre père jamais c'était donc sa
parole contre celle du gouvernement
à lessines style remet ces documents à
son avocat allan stein celui ci entame
une poursuite contre le gouvernement
fédéral au nom d'al sadd style qui agit
comme liquidatrice de la succession de
sa main le gouvernement finira par
offrir discrètement dédommagement à la
succession de jeans t il
mais l'entente doit demeurer
confidentielle ce que les gens imaginent
c'est si le gouvernement n'en parle pas
parce que il veut pas réveiller ceux qui
pourraient avoir un intérêt à poursuivre
est ce que c'est pour ça qu'on fait une
entente confidentielle exactement le
film et ce n'est pas diffusée l'histoire
de madame style en décembre dernier et
son avocat a reçu plusieurs appels
provenant d'enfants dit victime du
docteur cameron des personnes qui m'a
dit est ce qu'on peut intenter une
action nous affoler dommage qu'on a
subie après le traitement de ma mère ou
de mon père était un trépan s pas fuir
pas fusionner et l'impassibilité mais il
ya aussi une question de prescription au
civil une prescription 3 à 3 ans à
partir du moment où on prend
connaissance exactement
alors comment on explique que madame
style est réussie elle à obtenir une
compensation parce que sa mère a fait la
requête pour être compensées pendant la
période où on peut faire combien de
familles sont dans la même situation que
madame style parmi les 250 patients qui
ont vu leurs dossiers rejetés dans les
années 90 difficile à dire
le gouvernement actuel va peut-être
réalisé et reconnaître les gestes posés
par le gouvernement de l'époque il y a
peut être l'espoir qu'ils reconnaissent
au moins ce qu'ont vécu ses victimes
pour les victimes qui ont reçu cette
compensation ce n'est pas qu'une
question d'argent
d'accord j'ai reçu le dédommagement mais
l'important ça n'a pas été l'argent mes
yeux l'important c'était comme
confirmait que je n'étais pas
complètement folle et crise c'est ce
qu'on m'avait fait subir qui me faisait
faire des choses bizarres mais que
j'étais saine d'esprit en arrivant là
bas ça a été dur d'être privés de notre
maman elle souffre tellement quand elle
pense à tout ça alors je lui rappelle
que ce n'est pas sa faute mais que c'est
leur faute
j'ai demandé à ma mère qui était
présente et légendes comme en cent que
toi tu as laissé les médecins fait ce
qu'il a fait
puis elle m'a dit voir c'était des
années 50
le médecin était comme une vieux en 1964
le docteur johan carbone kit l'institut
à la memorial et retourne vivre aux
états unis
son successeur mais alors fin au type de
traitement privilégié par cameron il ne
se doutait pas que ces méthodes
rattraperait d'établissement et
entacherait sa réputation des années
plus tard
le docteur cameron demeure en 1967
c'est lié avec la cia n'ont jamais été
éclaircies
l'organisation a fait détruire
pratiquement tous les dossiers du projet
mk ultra dans les années 70 encore
aujourd'hui des centaines de canadiens
des victimes et leurs familles subissent
les conséquences des expériences financé
par les gouvernements canadien et
américain
pourtant depuis toutes ces années aucun
des deux pays ne leur a encore dit nous
sommes désolés
[Musique]
au nom de toute l'équipe on espère que
vous avez apprécié les reportages de ce
soir et puisque c'est la dernière de la
saison on veut justement remercier cette
équipe tous les journalistes tous les
réalisateurs qui nous permet de vous
présenter une émission exceptionnelle et
bien entendu l'équipe de production et
vous ne connaissez c'est pas parce que
l'émission fait relâche pour la saison
estivale qu'on arrête d'enquêté pour un
temps alors pour ça on a besoin de vous
parce que comme vous l'avez fait tout au
long de la saison
vous nous alimenter énormément
d'informations si vous avez des
suggestions des informations nous
transmettre nos adresses apparaissent au
bas de l'écran on a hâte de vous lire on
vous souhaite un très bel été et on se
retrouve au mois de septembre
[Musique]